[Music]
what's up everybody this is Lord
sovereign here coming to you live from
the Microsoft theater this is our post
Microsoft III briefing reaction we're
coming to you live lords of gaming
dotnet the iron Lords podcast I'm Lord
sovereign this is the boss Lord kognito
and of course Lord addict young wolf the
young wolf
so just to kick it off we have to say
all of us are extremely disappointed in
Microsoft showing today they showed some
cool games some new stuff that we
weren't expecting that was kind of cool
basically the whole first hour were
smaller games with a few few cool things
sprinkled in
we saw Ori we saw a new Blair which came
to look really good but beyond that
there was a lot of smaller games so we
figured that the second hour was gonna
be all the big hitters and first of all
there wasn't even a full second hour
there the whole show was maybe about an
hour and a half long and we heard that
it would be longer and it wasn't that
the end of the show obviously have
anybody who saw it ended with Halo with
a little bit of talk about next-gen and
console and a little bit of talk about
cloud but we didn't think it was
detailed enough to really really show
what this stuff is about so we were very
happy at the fact that Scarlett's coming
out 2020 halos launching with it so that
was cool but overall I have to tell you
very disappointed in the conference no
fable nothing from the initiative
nothing from the initiative and just
really nothing that's a little further
out just to give us a little taste of
what they what else they're working on
so I've always said III is the biggest
stage you have to come here you have to
show you have to drop the mic and they
they drop the ball not the mic they drop
the ball so I'll hand it off to the boss
some service a lot
look man on we all know the stakes here
we know they're the only show in town
right now
you know Sony's not here so the
the intention is you've got to show out
right you've got to lay all the chips on
the table initially I thought the show
started strong I thought the pacing was
boom boom I think that well I think they
fit in my opinion they fell off the
board after like after they hit the high
to me of like cyberpunk and wit comes
out to me that was like the building
erupted at that moon morning but again
the way I look at it that's not your IP
right this is a third party so this is
how I judge a show I'm looking at what
Microsoft has to show we're there were
some great games that were third party
look amazing the Namco game the tails
I'm a fantasy star God's sake it was in
the building I love those announcements
the game past the servers and stuff
great stuff you know I just felt from
Microsoft's own IP when they use those
numbers what was it a 40 or 60 game when
you use those numbers people want to see
exactly what the amount people want to
see high quality games coming from you
and from them those games I felt
underwhelmed after a lot of the indie
games that maybe got too much and maybe
could have been done like in a vision
and or something vignette or something
like that absolutely and just quickly
show them off but it felt like even
though Microsoft's to do stuff that they
were announcing and hey I love smaller
innovative games so I love that that's
not the point but again this is where
you show out your big guns right you had
anything to show anything anything from
fable if it is in fact being made if you
had anything from the initiative just
whatever right show it right show it to
get your base excited it was it was kind
of eerie to notice like the silence
after certain thing let's just talk
about let's get to it right after the
show in I'm like well that show started
that the show was that fever pitch when
that show ended any Xbox fan if you say
it to your heart not real you're not
being real it was a Morgan name when
actually ended it was like that that's
it you know what I'm saying like let's
just keep it a hundred like this is no
Xbox Bastion we just got to be honest
what the raw emotion of when the show
ended it was literally like somebody
that imma give it to added because I
know right now
you see I was watching his face during
the conference he's like cause I don't
know looking spooky so I'm gonna give it
the Attic man what was your impression
this thing I think it might be one of
the worst ones they've had in probably
five years I think that I get it
I thought the pacing was good but what
the what I didn't like about the pacing
is they tried to be too fast and I show
gameplay instead of showing an in depth
of what the what everyone wanted they
just showed a trailer like why did we
get some cake going crazy on the screen
instead it instead is something on the
gameplay like what they made the ma the
best games that are coming out this year
not look great how did not show a little
bit of story care and like one of the
biggest things that I'm just frustrated
with it's like they showed something
about halo but you apparently you were
flying to my acknowledged master chief
was definitely not in space at the end
of five so that makes no sense of that
we don't even know what kind of distance
and how long it's been since he's been
out of commission it looked like Cortana
was on his side at the end apparently at
the end she went crazy so I'm gonna have
to say man like this might be the worst
III that they could have possibly
dropped no the agent looked fantastic if
they useless wait why why didn't we get
it in depth what slit space can do like
why didn't we get ninja there they could
have showed a game white I get it they
don't want to show too much gameplay
because people would they were getting
clowned on for like the division stuff
but at the end of the day people
especially your IPS don't show dying
light don't show none of them when it
comes to gameplay but when it comes to
your IP you need gameplay max listen you
just nail what I was gonna give back you
saw that that what he said right there's
what what I felt like again the game's
look good but if you're a playstation
guy and you watch this show right you
like dying light yeah that's coming to
my joint um cyberpunk
yeah that's coming to my system so
anything that looked impressive people
are going to subtract points off top
because they're gonna say look I can get
that anywhere else you Microsoft has to
compel people that their software is
gonna make you come to this platform
you're not I mean and the Scarlet thing
even that was
little underwhelmed it was almost like a
remix of the of the elder of the ex
trailer you don't saying guys executives
talking yeah it was just they use bait
the same sort of format from when they
announced the ex right and you know it
was just underwhelming like everybody's
knows the Scarlett name and you know and
that's another thing the way they seem
to announce it it felt like there is no
to skews it there now Scarlett is one
thing and and we talked about it maybe
they just don't want to talk about the
Lord's doing I'm talking about the
high-end right cool but it just it just
felt underwhelming yeah so the coolest
thing about it is that is launching next
year and is launching with Halo beta
launches with the console since the
original console I think that's big but
beyond that again
I just think very disappointed they did
not seize the opportunity right and I
don't understand why right all right and
I whatever to actually flip it right now
I want to say okay attic like what are
just what as a question just just foot
it for the sake of fairness what
impressed you give me some things that
you actually liked about this conference
I like the pacing I know you didn't but
I thought the pacing was okay there's
difference between pacing and good
pacing that has nothing the pacing was
good but the content was bad I liked the
I liked what they showed on hail I felt
like something different could have been
there
I don't know see it's hard for me to
find positive things some of the games
are fun Blair which I thought that was
Silent Hill for a second it was looking
like silent Double Fine school school
but like at the end of the day light it
wasn't the magnifying thing like double
fine I don't feel like that's III worthy
like they could have literally have done
that at inside Xbox too but the last one
that they did unless they were going to
show multiple now if they were going to
show multiple that's that's III worthy
but I don't think just Double Fine's III
worth I don't think that this is like
the jury if Sony was here this has
completely dropped of all like they just
got shot out in the street they got they
got bad but since Sony's not here I feel
like they went for a safe direction they
didn't have no competition
and that's not the time like you it's
like easing off the brakes right before
you hit the finish slide when what Saudi
literally stood there at the finish line
I think for me I didn't addict nailed it
best I think he's making a good point as
far as pacing he's right I mean it was
sped up it wasn't like too drawn-out
again I pacing feels went once the
content is not what you want yeah then
no matter how good the patient is
because I started yawning and I'm like
and it was still bang bang bang bang
bang yeah yeah
it just wasn't anything that I wanted
Riya yeah I feel like what they could
have done to make the show way better is
they gotta have some gameplay on halo
they have to like what they could have
just took all the indie stuff stuff the
big big inning stuff and put that all in
one rail and then they take that time
they take that dedication time that 2-3
minutes apiece and give that two gears
take that two or three minutes apiece
give that to Halo show us some actual
like you literally showed us Master
Chief walking across the ship let you
match this game's coming out next year
why didn't we see any major gameplay
what I can actually understand the halo
reveal I thought it might be an issue a
lot of some a little bit of premise we
don't know about the continuity but they
show a little press I'm more
disappointed in the gears ask me because
this is coming out this year right now
granted they showed escape that looked
cool the little three three room the
ruled level thing cool I mean they show
features of it but I guess I just my
thing is we need to see a little bit of
their campaign we like it needed to be
reversed yeah show us that multiplayer
stuff at an inside Xbox yes and you show
us the campaign III yeah it was almost
like why are you holding back now this
is the time to show out this game yeah
it just feels like this restraint yeah
no reason yeah you have people coming
here people flipping out trying to get
into this conference every single year
like forget about this year every single
year yeah to me it's a kind of respect
for your fan to come in here and then
act like this is this is it and again I
like completely respect the amount of
work that goes into anything a huge big
games ball game but this you need to
show out on the e3
like what what I thought they were gonna
do is I said it in my actual prediction
III kind of I didn't call halo I did say
it could be halo that they were going to
show the console and then they were
gonna show game kind of like but I
thought what what I thought they're
gonna do in the pacing cuz I still
thought that was gonna be fable it show
that show halo and then right before
he's about to close the story we got one
more game for you like all that woulda
took is just I really think like the
what was missing from this is a banger
something that we can do they needed a
surprise we also had heard rumors of
like maybe Nintendo maybe they needed an
earth-shattering surprise to say Oh
something that's oh my god drop worthy
the biggest oMG moments is Phantasy Star
Online 2 yeah you know like and I would
I mean I was super happy know ready for
everything for everybody I was super
happy but at the same time and not to
mention no no from software gameplay
yeah I mean I go crazy we don't know
that right again it's just to me yeah
forget about the third party your stuff
yes that's what ignore stuff that's what
it comes out to me like soldiers nailed
it for me it which is when it but it's
your titles you've got to showcase
you've got to you've got to get people
excited about your stuff because again
the consensus is you're gonna show a
bunch of multi plats
they're gonna look better on your
console we know that but what are you
doing and everything that they had
outside of Halo which we know has
launched as a big announcement you know
I'm saying but outside of they have what
they have for this year I can't say I
was like super pumped up and we got to
say that is disappointing you you've got
you're the only show in town you've got
to show up you've got to blow the doors
oh so that's what I'm gonna end it with
final reviews after you talk like you're
gonna give it a green yeah and I just
want to put some like you know
some thought process behind it's like
think about this we saw more gameplay
from ori than we saw from gears that we
saw from halo from Ori and this games
coming out this year gears 5 is coming
out in like three months why didn't we
see it like just all you would sees like
the beginning cutscene or something
something all they show is like they
what it is if for some reason they don't
want to show gameplay now that's just
frustrating to the music in the builder
so real quick y'all we just seen him we
don't seem all that pleased but I want
to do what's our rating it was just
we're gonna do like eight let's do let
is let's do that is show this party like
I said the Blair Witch stuff was
surprising I enjoyed that those bleeding
eyes look good I'm a Power Stone head in
it and it looked like a refined Power
Stone and I know
ninja Terry knows their combat that
looked for it very cool um what else
Eric I need your ranking man they showed
him infected but not even really wide
what that even means like with his
slight turning red he's like what I'm
infected BAM gone over next trailer
weight was gears tactic said why did I
get was just that was the one I was
looking for bro so I'm hurt
I want to say that I had except it
wasn't gonna be there and if it was
gonna be there they would say stick
that's gonna be at the PC gaming show
[Music]
but I didn't say for Xbox console right
they J the BC so man so you said C
c-minus
like it was the worst show ever done
right but based on the circumstances
circumstances for this year if they
would've did this show last year yeah it
would have been even worse but since
they did it this year and there's not a
competition
I'm sorry
the lack of Sony being here does not
excuse this sorry it's still a business
trip I get it like you have something to
compare it to I have a feeling that
endows gonna eat their lunch I have a
feeling and we were like I told you like
45 minutes in I was like this is bad you
were saying during the conference
Atticus like yo this is looking spooky
he's like y'all I don't know and I'm
trying to keep it together and I'm
feeling what he's feeling but you say
all right let me end it man cuz is it
thing I've warned people when you hear
words like forty exclusives and keep
things in perspective there's a lot of
hyperbole sometimes marketing
terminology look I gotta be I gotta tell
you my royal feelings I didn't feel good
leaving there I didn't feel got to feel
confident like yo this is something
crazy right I mean listen I'm buying it
you know that but it's just again I
gotta say see it's just with the
pressure they had everything on the line
no Sony here you've got to show oh I
didn't feel wild I didn't feel blown
away
I just felt safe I felt controlled we're
not gonna give them this and then also I
felt a little remix again with the
scarlet announcement that felt like an
ex remixed by Jeanette I mean you know
and to be honest I want a little bit
more on Project X cloud I understand
they were saying you know they were
gonna you know do the public trial right
the fact that they announced that now
your council itself that was dull that's
very quick they got an A for network
this hour look at it they got an A - B
for services dave has not all that was
cool
but the games what we're here for and
get but the geeks I gotta say see man I
mean it was very average pedestrian
nothing is what that's what I got man so
this is wrong reactions with the Lord's
iron law podcast loads of gaming down
there yo check it out we got our life
we've got a love blog up I got some
reactions did while it was going down
and that's what we got iron law podcast
and we out brothers but that's the next
let's go y'all we out word